[Music]
pick it here misshapen
now we're doing them
my name is sergeant Robert Gomez with
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
syllabus come home initial reports good
advice
suspects
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
tactically for me from this location any
more confirmed concrete information will
come from city leaders from the EEOC I
mean the car of Correction the EEOC on
Threadgill that vocation will be
announced and you'll be able to hear
from our city leaders Chief of Police
marriage so forth with more concrete
information this location will be the
tactical brief giving you updates of
where we need people to go what we need
people to do and the status of the scene
itself at this time I'll take any
questions at this time we have ruled out
multiple shooters it's still active but
as of right now we have one person in
custody we know I don't have this I'll
have the status of a suspect right now I
don't have that confirmation I know we
do have injured I don't know their
status or if there's any confirmed kill
as soon as we have that information
we'll provide it but we don't want to do
anything prematurely until we have
accurate facts for you
[Music]
right now we're clearing all the
location this is a very large area
including the mall all the retail areas
we are going through making sure that
anybody that locked in was that's
sheltered in place that we get to them
we're also treating any persons that
were injured in any form so this is a
large crime scene a large area so we are
systematically going through it and
making sure that anybody in the area
number one we're really not that no one
is a suspect and we're also making sure
that those people that were separated or
hurt are getting the care that they need
I don't know how publications of the
castle tees I just know that there are
casualties I don't know that the actual
locations
yes there were reports of gunfire and in
several locations Maine mainly Walmart
and the syllabus tomorrow sir we have
reports that Bassett was also evacuated
we did have initial reports of classic
center I can confirm that those reports
were not true we have confirmed that
there is nothing going on related to
this incident at Bassett center I don't
know the status of them I know medical
personnel isn't attending to them I
don't know if they're at the location
where they've been transported I know
there's mixed up information on that as
soon as I have an accurate count I will
give it to you what about reports of one
person arrested on the weight of the
rice I don't have any reports of a
person arrested in horizon I do know
that we have one person detained one
person in custody right now I don't have
the location of that test another where
that person was detained but as soon as
I get that and we that will have more
concrete information will provide it in
espanol I made a cell phone English
primero you know respond
additional reports of the weapon was a
rifle I can't confirm that yet but
initial reports was a rifle hey did you
angrily
and we have no release we have no
information and we have not put out
concrete response on what the motive for
this shooting is we are working that
like I said we are transitioning into
the crime scene phase and we will be
developing more information as that
becomes available to us and as we learn
it and we can run the same search we
help allow the apostle police department
House District University
we are working with our federal partners
FBI is I see
all the federal agencies are here
assisting because this is a large area
we do have assistance from the Sheriff's
Department the school district pretty
much every law enforcement personnel in
El Paso resources
but we are working closely with our
federal partners our state partners and
all the other law enforcement in this
area but you know we're still developing
that as soon as I have company
I ever raise sex
no I don't have anything the only thing
I have this is up mail as of right now
we have one person in custody
I don't know that particulars or if
there are more than one there were
initial reports of one but we have one
person in custody so that's the only
thing I don't know the ages or the
casual know the way have one person in
custody as of right now
as far as I know no I don't have the
condition of any casualties at all
whether they're fatalities or injured
I can only see one person in custody
right now
I can't definitively say they're home
there were shots fired they were shots
fired in this area
I'm sorry Mike
okay just to be clear this thing is food
and
but that could change initial reports
where there was more to look at this
second in time we have one person in
custody
we won't roll out multiple until we have
a concrete investigation based on all
the facts an investigation at the scene
so it can change as of this moment we
only have one person in custody
- getting the crime scene should it
change we will give you an update but
that's right now that's the information
my gonna
Central Command